Nanoteknoloji ve sürdürülebilirlik
kısmına devam ediyoruz. Bugün nano
parçacıklardan sürdürülebilirlikle
ilgili detaylardan bahsedeceğim.
İstersen vakit kaybetmeyelim. Hazırsan
başlayalım. Şimdi nanometreden ve
nanoteknolojiden bahsetmiştik. Nano
parçacıklardan kısaca bahsetmiştik. İşte
bu derste metal nano parçacıklardan
bahsedeceğiz ki bunlar çok değerlidir.
Şöyle söyleyelim. Metal nano
parçacıklara şöyle metal NP ismini
veriyoruz. Böyle bir kısaltma
yapabiliriz. Mesela büyüklükler işte 1
nanometre ile 100 nanometre arasındaki
büyüklüklerdir. Bunlar da şöyle bir şey
vardır. Genel olarak bu parçacıklar
bulunduğu karışımda koloidal olarak
bulunmaktadır. Koloidal parçacıklardır
şeklinde söylüyoruz. Yaygın olarak
nerelerde kullanılıyor dersek
elektronik, kozmetik, kaplama,
paketleme, biyoteknoloji gibi alanlarda
kullanılmakta. Mesela bak örnek vermiş
bir tane. Bu önemli bir örnektir. Bazen
bununla ilgili şeyler duyarsın. İşte
gümüş içeren bilmem ne
mikroorganizmaları öldürüyor falan gibi
ifadeler kullanırlar. Mesela çoraplarda
falan vardı galiba. İşte bak gümüş bu
nano parçacık dediğimiz şeyler gıda
saklama uygulamalarında, ev aletlerinde
bak antibakteriyel özelliğe sahip sağlık
endüstrisinde ve tekstil ürünlerinde
kullanılıyor. Yani bu çoraplarda falan
kullanılıyor. Bazılarında var bu. Niye?
Bazısının ayakları maşallah biliyorsun.
Yani ölü gibi kokuyor. Yani diğer bir
ifadeyle böyle adamın ayağı ölmüş,
gömmeyi unutmuşlar. Vücudunda beraber
gezdiriyor. Öyle kötü kokanlar var
mesela. İşte o neyden kaynaklanıyor?
bakterilerden kaynaklanıyor. İşte bu
gümüş nano parçacıkları içeren şeyler
çoraplar giydiğinde burada bakteri
oluşumunu engelliyor veya işte
bakterileri öldürüyor falan. Bundan
dolayı da ayak kokmuyor. Hani ne kadar
idare ediyor onu bilemiyorum ama sonuçta
belki bir yıkamadan sonra eski haline
geliyor olabilir. O yine muhteşem peynir
kokusu yani o şu küflenmiş peynir kokusu
yine gelebilir orada. Ama genel olarak
bunu kullananlar var. Mesela bakırdan
yapılan bakır nano parçacıklar var ki
bunlar da işte elektrik iletkenliği çok
yüksektir. Normal bakır metaline göre
daha yüksek bir elektrik iletkenliğine
sahip. Bununla boyalar yapıyorlar.
Mesela elektrik iletkeni boyalar var.
Adam mesela devreyi kuruyor. O boyayı
çekiyor. Şöyle bir değdiriyor diğer
tarafa. Devre tamamlanıyor mesela.
Yanmaya başlıyor. İşte onun içerisinde
neler var? Bakır nanoparçacıklar var. Bu
işte elektrik iletkeni olan
mürekkeplerin yapımında başka işte
elektrik devrelerinde, başka çiplerde,
elektronik tekstil kıyafetlerinde
bunların hepsinde ne yapılıyor? İşte
bunlar kullanılabiliyor. Şimdi şöyle bir
şey vardır. Nanoteknolojik ürünleri
nasıl elde ediyorlar? En önemli
şeylerden bir tanesi budur ki bir ara
ben de bununla ilgili ilgilenmiştim.
Hatta böyle bir şey kurma, eee, şirket
kurma şeyleri de olmuştu. Sonradan
vazgeçtik. Yıllar öncesinden
bahsediyorum. Teknolojiyi tam olarak
bilmiyoruz. Bilen kişilerle böyle bir
araya gelmiştik. Böyle bir çalışma da
yapmaya çalışmıştım ama olmadı.
İstediğim gibi olmadı. Burada mesela
şöyle bir yöntem kullanılıyor. Bir
yukarıdan aşağı dediğimiz bir yöntem
var. Yani büyük parçacığı nano parçacığa
çevirme diye bir şey var. Bir de
aşağıdan yukarıya dediğimiz bir şey var
ki o da atomdan nano parçacığa doğru
yukarıya doğru çıkma. İşte bu iki
yöntemle nanoteknolojik ürünler elde
edilebiliyor. Burada da söylüyor işte
yukarıdan aşağı yönteminde enerji
kullanılarak yığınlar halindeki
parçacıklar neye dönüştürülüyor? Nano
boyuta dönüştürülüyor. Mesela kurşun
kalemin ucu neydi? grafitti. İşte bu
grafiti ne yapıyorlar? Nano parçacıklara
dönüştürebiliyorlar ki o nedir? Mesela
grafen dediğimiz yapı. Buna
dönüştürebiliyorlar. Bu işte yukarıdan
aşağı dediğimiz yöntem. Aşağıdan yukarı
dediğimiz yöntemde ise atomik ya da
moleküler boyuttaki malzemeleri
tepkimeye sokarak ne yapıyorlar? Nano
parçacığa yukarıya doğru çıkıyorlar.
Burada da işte çeşitli şeyler elde
ediliyor. Yani birçok ürün elde
edilebiliyor. Hatta bununla ilgili eee
şey vardı. Yıllar önce görmüştüm. Mesela
nano boyutlarda Türk bayrağı yapmış.
Mesela nanoteknolojiyle Türk bayrağı
yapmış. Bununla ilgili de internette
ararsan görsellerini bulabilirsin. E
tabii bu nano parçacıklar nerelerde çok
kullanılıyor? İşte biyoteknolojilerde,
kimyasal ve biyolojik sentezlerde çok
kullanılıyor. Bak burada mesela grafit
ne yapılıyor işte bak görüyor musun?
Normalde şunların her birisi bir grafen
tabakası. İşte grafiti ne yapıyorsun?
Ayırarak bu grafenleri elde ediyorsun.
İşte bu nano parçacık dediğimiz durum ne
yapıyor? Bu yukarıdan aşağı dediğimiz
yöntemle yapılıyor. Ha bak burada da
gösteriyor işte yukarıdan aşağı ve
aşağıdan yukarı dediğimiz durum ne
yapılıyor? yağın halindekileri
parçalayarak nano parçacığa
dönüştürüyorlar. Şeyde ise aşağıdan
yukarı dediğimiz yöntemde ise atom veya
molekülleri birleştirerek kümeler haline
getirerek ne yapıyorlar? Nano parçacığa
ulaşıyorlar. Ve bu aşağıdan yukarıda ne
yapılıyor? İşte bu yaklaşımda kimyasal
sentezle de yapılabiliyor, biyolojik
sentezle de yapılabiliyor. İşte bu
biyolojik sentezle yapılanlara biz yeşil
sentez ismini veriyoruz. Şimdi bu nano
boyuttaki parçacıkları aşağıdan yukarıya
doğru elde ederken eğer kimyasal sentez
kullanıyorsak burada bir sürü zararlı
yabancı böyle parçacıklar çıkabiliyor.
Burada da bundan bahsediyor. İşte
kimyasal sentez yönteminde kimyasal
maddelerin yol açtığı birçok çevresel ve
biyolojik zararlar olmaktadır. Ekonomik
açıdan yüksek maliyetlidir bunlar. İşte
günümüzde de nano parçacıkların
eldesinde ekonomik, çevre dostu, toksik
olmayan yöntemler kullanılmaya e
başlandı ki buna biz yeşil sentez
diyoruz. İşte yeşil sentezde genellikle
biyolojik sentezler kullanmakta. Neler
var mesela yeşil sentez işleminde? Evsel
atıklar, bakteri, maya, bitkilerin kök,
gövde, yaprak ve çiçek gibi kısımları
kullanılmakta. Bunlardan elde
edilebiliyor. Mesela ne yapıyor?
Böylelikle çevreye zarar vermemiş
oluyoruz. İşte bu yeşil sentezle ne
yapmış oluyoruz? Bu metal
nanoparçacıklara dönüşüm işleminde yani
inorganik metal iyonlarını metal
nanoparçacığa dönüştürürken daha az
kimyasal kullanmış oluyoruz. Bu da
çevreye zararı azaltmış oluyor. Bu yeşil
sentez yönteminde olay şudur. Mesela
metal iyonlarının haricindeki tüm
kimyasalların yerine ne yapıyoruz? İşte
doğadan elde edilebilecek malzemeleri
evsel ve endüstriyel veya sanayi
atıklarını kullanıyoruz. Böylelikle
atığı da geri dönüştürmüş oluyoruz. Yani
atıktan da kurtulmuş oluyoruz. hem nano
parçacık elde etmiş oluyoruz, hem
çevreyi daha az kirletmiş oluyoruz hem
de çevreye verilecek zararlı maddeleri
dönüştürdüğümüz için bir geri dönüşüm de
yapmış oluyoruz. İşte burada da tam
olarak bunu söylüyor. İşte atıkların
geri kazanılması, doğanın korunması ve
ekolojik sürdürebilirlik,
sürdürülebilirlik açısından faydalı bir
durumdur. Şimdi o zaman şöyle yapalım.
Yeşil kimyadan bahsedelim. Yani işte bu
sürdürülebilirliğin çevre dostu kimyasal
yöntemlerinden bahsedelim. İşte bu yeşil
kimyanın ilkelerini şöyle bir tablo
haline getirmişiz. Bak şöyle dur. Heh
küçülteyim birazcık. Neler var? Atık
önleme var. Atom teknolojisi var.
Bunları tek tek böyle açıklayacağım
şimdi. Daha az kimyasal sentez. Başka?
Daha güvenli kimyasallar tasarlamak.
Daha güvenli çözücüler ve yardımcı
maddeler. Enerji verimliliği için
tasarım. Başka ne var? İşte
yenilenebilir ham maddeler. Daha yeşil
sentez. Yan ürünlerin azaltılması,
kataliz, bozulma tasarımı, başka ne var?
işte gerçek zamanlı kirlilik analizi ve
kazanın önlenmesi ve daha güvenilir bir
kimya. Böyle bir yeşil sentezden
bahsediyoruz. Kademeleri bunlar. Onları
da şöyle açıklayalım. İşte bu ilkelerden
bahsedersek atık önleme nedir? Kimyasal
işlemler sonucunda ortaya çıkan atık
oluşumunu en aza indirmek ya da tamamen
ortadan kaldırmak için yapılan bir
şeydir. Atom ekonomisi dediğimiz
hammaddeyi en verimli şekilde kullanarak
atık oluşumunu da azaltmış oluyoruz ve
böylelikle verimi de ne yapmış oluyoruz?
Arttırmış oluyoruz. Yani şöyle bir şey,
kullandığın ürünü o kadar böyle
miktarında kullanıyorsun ki ne fazla, ne
çok fazla, ne az. Tam kıvamında ama
minimuma indirecek şekilde
kullanıyorsun. İşte buna da atom
ekonomisi ismini veriyoruz. Daha az
tehlikeli kimyasal sentez dediğimizde
ise toksik etkisi olmayan veya çok az
olan maddeleri üretmek. E haliyle bu ne
yapacaktır? insan sağlığı ve çevreyi
korumuş olacaktır. Daha güvenli
kimyasallar tasarlama istenilen
özelliklere sahip birçok madde
kullanılıyor. Bunu tabii bununla alakalı
değil de farklı bir örnek üzerinden
vereyim. Mesela klimalarda kullanılan
bir gaz vardır. Daha önce o
kullanılıyordu. Freon gazı diye bir gaz
kullanılıyordu. Bu atmosfere ciddi
zararlıydı. İşte ozon tabakasına zarar
veriyordu. Sera etkisi yapıyordu. E
dediler ki ya bunun yerine bir şey
bulamaz mıyız? Ne buldular? İşte farklı
gazlar buldular. Böyle R bilmem ne böyle
değişik değişik kodları vardı. Mesela
Pron gazı mesela. farklı farklı gazlar
kullanmaya başladılar. Yine soğutma
etkisini sağlıyor ama çevreye daha az
zarar veriyor. İşte bunun gibi bir
durumdan bahsediyoruz. Daha güvenli
kimyasallar tasar tasarlama dediğimizde
istenilen özelliklere sahip toksik
etkisi minimum seviyeye indirilmiş
kimyasalların tasarlanmasından
bahsediyoruz. Şimdi birçok kimyasal
işleminde yani kimyasal tepkimede
çözücüler kullanılmakta. İşte daha
güvenli çözücü ve yardımcı maddeler
dediğimiz durumsa şu kimyasal işlemler
sırasında çözücülerin ve yardımcı
maddelerin kullanımını en aza indirmeye
çalışıyoruz. Hatta gerekmiyorsa
kullanmamaya çalışıyoruz. İşte bu da ne?
Yeşil sentezin, yeşil kimyanın
ilkelerinden bir tanesi. Enerji
verimliliği için tasarım ki bu çok çok
önemlidir. Yani bir ürünü elde etmek
için ne kadar az enerji
kullanabiliyorsak bunun için
çalışıyoruz. Temel amacımız bu. Yüksek
verimli ve enerji tasarruflu kimyasal
tasarım sürecini gerçekleştirme
dediğimiz olaydır bu. Böylelikle daha az
atık oluşuyor, daha az kirlilik oluşuyor
ve daha fazla tasarruf sağlanmış oluyor.
Hem ülke ekonomisine ne yapıyorsun?
Fayda sağlamış oluyorsun. Hem enerji hem
de enerji verimliliği sağlamış
oluyorsun. Bunların hepsi nedir? Ciddi
bir faydadır. Ne diyor? yenilebilir
hammaddelere daha yeşil sentezler
dediğimizde ise işte bu süreçte
hammaddelerin yenilenebilir ve
sürdürülebilir olmasının sağlanması yani
bir hammaddeyi ben aldım kullandım bitti
e tekrar almam gerekiyor. Örnek
veriyorum işte petrol ürünlerinden
bahsedelim. E petrol ürünlerini ne
yapıyorsun? Alıyorsun, kullanıyorsun. E
onu kullandıktan sonra bir daha petrol
ürünü almak zorundasın. İşte bu
yenilenebilir ve sürdürülebilir
durumdaysa olay şu. Ben aldım,
kullandım, harcadım. O dönüştü, tekrar
doğaya verildi. Tekrar aldım, tekrar
kullandım. Bir döngü sağlamış oluyorsun.
Bunu daha önce anlattığımız derslerde de
söylemiştik. Bunu e diğer abilerinize,
ablalarınıza anlattığımız kısımlarda da
vardı bu mesele. Örnek vereyim. Mısırdan
elde edilen bir şey vardır ki işte
etanol elde ediliyor. Eee, şey
yapıyorlar. Önce mısırın nişastasını
çıkarıyorlar. Bu nişastayı çıkarttıktan
sonra glikoza dönüştürüyorlar.
Fermentasyon işlemleriyle bunu
dönüştürdükten sonra da yakıt olarak
kullanıyorlar. Mesela biyoetanol
dediğimiz bir yakıt var. Orada
kullanıyorlar. E ne yaptık bak?
Mısır'dan aldık bunu. Dönüştürdük.
Yakıta kattık. Yaktık. Doğaya
karbondioksit olarak verildi. Mısır
bitkisi tekrar o karbondioksiti aldı.
Tekrar nişastaya dönüştürdü. Bak ne
yaptık? Bir döngü sağladık. İşte
yenilenebilir derken bunu kastediyoruz.
Bu tabii basit bir örneği. Tabii bunu
tam olarak açıklamıyor da yani bu basit
bir örneği bu şekilde kafanda
tasarlayabilirsin. Yani ne demek
istediğimi buradan yorumlayabilirsin.
Yani yenilenebilir ve sürdürülebilir
hammaddeler üretmek. Bu da önemli bir
ilkedir. E haliyle kimyasal tepkimelerin
en kötü tarafı yan ürün oluşturmasıdır.
Yani yan bir atık madde oluşturma
ihtimalidir. Ki burada da bunu söylüyor.
Kimyasal süreçte atık oluşumunu azaltmak
amacıyla gereksiz işlemlerin tümünü
ortadan çıkartma işlemidir bu. Yani
bazen bir deney yapıyorsun, bir işlem
yapıyorsun, bir ürün elde edeceksin. 5
kademeli bir işlem. Orada mesela
kademelerden birini azaltarak yan ürün
oluşumunu azaltıyorlar veya işte farklı
bir kimyasal sistem oluşturup üç
kademede gerçekleştiriyorlar belki. Yani
işte bunun için çalışıyor yeşil kimya.
Kataliz dediğimiz olay aslında
reaksiyonu hızlandıran bir şeydir. Yani
kimyasal tepkimeye girer, tepkimeyi
hızlandırır ve daha kısa sürede daha
verimli bir verimli demeyeyim de yani
daha kısa sürede gerçekleşmesini sağlar
ve enerji tasarrufu sağacaktır. Daha
kısa sürede gerçekleştiği için enerji
tasarrufu sağlayan, daha az zararlı
tepkime koşulları sağlayan ve seçiciliği
artıran katalizörler kullanılması
olayıdır. Ki mesela bir kimyasal tepkime
örnek vereyim ne olsun? vücudumuzda
gerçekleşen bir şeydir. Mesela glikozun
karbondioksit ve işte suya ayrışması
olayını dışarıda gerçekleştirmeye
kalksak ne yapacağız? Yakacağız.
Yandıktan sonra işte ortalığa işte
bayağı bir enerji harcaman gerekecek
falan. Ama aynısını vücut da yapıyor.
Vücut ne yapıyor? Ama enzimlerle yani
katalizörlerle gerçekleştiriyor bunu.
Daha az enerji kullanıyor ve daha
verimli bir şekilde yapmış oluyor bunu.
İşte kimyasal sentezlerde de yeşil
kimyada ilkelerden bir tanesi bu. İşte
katalizörlere uygun katalizörleri
bularak ne yapıyorlar? daha kısa sürede
daha verimli bir dah enerji verimliliği
sağlayan bir sistem geliştiriyorlar.
Mesela kimyasal sentezlerde bu
bozunmalar vardır. Yani maddeleri
ayrıştırma dediğimiz bir olay vardır ki
bu ayrıştırma sonucunda oluşan maddeler
bazen zararlı olabiliyor. İşte
bozulmalar sonucunda daha az zarar veren
ve doğada daha kısa sürede yok olabilen
kimyasalların tasarlanması. Buna mesela
şeye örnek verebiliriz. Eskiden şeyler
işte bu poşetler şunlar bunlar neydi?
Petrolden elde ediliyordu ve doğada
çözünmüyordu. Çok zararlıydı. Şimdi
yavaş yavaş polikarbonat dediğimiz veya
işte farklı maddeler var. İşte bunlarla
ilgili şey çalışmalar yapılıyor. Mesela
bak bununla ilgili bir tane örnek
vereyim. Gliserin, eee, sirke. Birazcık
sirke, nişasta. Bunları karıştırarak
mesela böyle şey yaparak, ısıtarak
karıştırdığında bir jelimsi bir yapı
elde ediyorsun. Bunu böyle kuruttuğunda
aslında biyoplastik elde etmiş
oluyorsun. Biyoplastik kapları mesela bu
şekilde yapabiliyorlar. Belki tepkimenin
içerisindeki maddelerden inşallah
unuttuğum yoktur ama ben böyle yaptığımı
hatırlıyorum şu anda. İşte bu mesela
biyoplastik eldesinde kullanılan bir
yöntem. İşte ne yapıyor? Doğada
çözülüyor. Çevreye zararlı değil. İşte
bu şeylerin de kullandıkları tabii daha
kalitelisinden bahsediyoruz. Bu şeylerin
eee marketlerin falan kullandıkları
biyoplastik doğada çözünen plastikler
yani poşetler yapmaya başladık. Bu daha
da gelişecek tabii ki. Gerçek zamanlı
kirlilik analizi işte bu şudur. Kimyasal
sürecin izlenmesi ve kontrolün
sağlanması. Yani kimyasal tepkime
gerçekleşiyor. O sırada çıkan atın
yaptığı etkiyi hemen inceliyorlar. İşte
gerçek zamanlı kirlilik analiziyle ha
bak bu zararlı. Hemen ne yapıyorlar?
İşte şeyi değiştiriyorlar. Sistemi
değiştiriyorlar. Daha az zararlıya
dönüştürmeye çalışıyorlar. Hemen böyle
anında analiz yaparak işlemlere devam
ediyorlar. Ve tabii ki kimyada olmazsa
olmaz şeylerden bir tanesi de kazanın
önlenmesi ve daha güvenli bir kimya
dediğimiz olay şu ki ben sakar bir
insanımdır. Bayağı bir e
laboratuvarlarda kaza eee geçirmişliğim
vardır. Hatta bununla ilgili eee kötü
olaylarım da vardır. Yani bir yangındı,
şuydu, buydu ufak çaplı bir yangına da
sebebiyet vermişliğim vardır. Yani eee
dikkat etmek gerekiyor. Benim gibi
olmamanız gerekiyor. Çünkü deney
sırasında herhangi bir şey olabilir.
Yani karıştırılan maddeler birden
tepkimeye girebilir. Bundan dolayı da
daha güvenli bir ortam sağlamak
zorundasın. Eldivense eldiven, gözlükse
gözlük, işte kıyafetse kıyafet, bunların
hepsine uymak gerekiyor. Burada da
söylüyor işte süreçte kullanılacak
kimyasal maddelerin olası kaza riskini
en aza indirecek şekilde seçilmesi
gerekiyor. Yani orada kullanacağın
kimyasal örnek veriyorum işte sülfürik
asit kullandığında çok tehlikelidir.
Bunu kullanmak yerine şu an uyduruyorum
tabii ki sirke yani asetik asit
kullandığında da oluyorsa o zaman onu
kullan. Çünkü o daha az zarar verecek.
sülfürik asit kadar tehlikeli değildir.
Ya bu tabii şey yapıyorum şu an örnek
olarak veriyorum. Haliyle tabii ki bizim
ülkemiz de gelişmekte olan ülkelerden
bir tanesidir ki ne yapıyor? Kimya
sektörüne önem veriyor. Bir sürü sektöre
önem veriyor. Buralarda sürekli kimyasal
tepkimeler gerçekleşiyor ki bu arttıkça
ne oluyor? Atık yönetimini kontrol etmek
zorundasın. Çünkü fazlaca atık çıkmaya
başlıyor. İşte burada da tüketim hızı ve
üretim tüketim hızı artınca beraberinde
atık sorunu ve hammadde sıkıntısını da
beraberinde getirmekte. Örnek vereyim.
Şu anda mesela dünyada ciddi şekilde
gelişen bir teknoloji var ki bu da
nedir? Bu pil teknolojisi. Özellikle
lityum piller mesela. E sürekli
üretiyorsun. Eee doğadan çıkarttın
lityumu. Çıkart çıkart çıkart. Eee yani
bir yerde şey yapmak zorundasın. Sıkıntı
çekiyorsun. Ne yapman gerekiyor? Geri
dönüşüm yapman gerekiyor. Eski cep
telefonları şunlar bunlar dikkat edin.
Şarjlı pilleri şey yapılır ayrıştırılır.
Yani o lityum piller ayrıştırılır.
Tekrar lityum oradan elde edilip tekrar
pile dönüştürülür. Çünkü bu dönüşüm
lazım, ihtiyaçtır. İşte gelişmekte olan
ülkelerde şu anda bu sorun artmaya
başladı. O yüzden geri dönüşümün de
artması gerekiyor tabii ki. İşte bu
yeşil kimyayla ne hedefleniyor? Bak
yeşil kimya bu saydığımız ilkelerle
hedeflediğimiz şey ne? Şu bir doğal
kaynakların verimli kullanımı, atık
üretiminin önlenmesi veya işte atığın
azaltılması, geri kazanım yoluyla
hammadde ihtiyacının azaltılması,
kimyasal maddelerin ve atıkların çevre
dostu yönetimi, sürdürülebilir
kalkınmanın bilincinin artırılması
hedeflenmektedir. Temel amaç bunlardır
işte. Yani bunları yaparak aslında ne
yapmış oluyoruz? Gelecek nesillere daha
güzel bir dünya bırakmaya çalışıyoruz.
Temel amacımız bu. Herkesin olmasa da
genel olarak temel amacımız bu dostum.
Bak soruda ne diyor. Yeşil kimyanın
temel hedefleri arasında
sürdürülebilirlikte devamlılık. Evet,
sürdürülebilirlik önemli bir şeydi
demiştik. Alternatif enerji
kaynaklarının artırılması, kullanımının
artırılması. Evet. Tarım arazilerinde ne
yapıyormuş? Endüstriyel merkezlerin
kurulması. Ya bu yapılabilecek en büyük
yanlıştır. Tarım arazisi bize lazım.
Gıda ihtiyacı ileride belki gıda
sıkıntıları yaşanacak. Tarım arazilerine
endüstriyel fabrikalar kurmak kadar
büyük bir hata olamaz. Çünkü orada
tarıma elverişli toprak olduğu için
oranın tarımla devam etmesi gerekiyor.
Hatta böyle sürdürülebilir tarıma
geçilmesi gerekiyor. Oralara fabrika
kurmak, şunu bunu yapmak çok büyük bir
yanlıştır. E fabrika kuracaksan çok
böyle kıraç veya işte ne bileyim şeye
tarıma elverişli olmayan bir sürü arazi
var. Buralar tercih edilebilir. Ha o
zaman ne oldu cevabımız? yer almaz
dediği için B seçeneği. Burada diyor ki
nano parçacık eldesinde kullanılan
yukarıdan aşağı yaklaşımda yukarıdan
aşağı büyük parçayı ufaltarak küçüğe
dönüştürüyoruz. Nano parçacığa
dönüştürüyoruz. Hangileri örnek
verilebilir? Kurşun kalem ucundan grafen
eldesi. Evet kurşun kalem ucu büyüktü.
Parçaladık. Grafene dönüştürdük.
Yukarıdan aşağı yöntemiydi. Başka?
Altının toz haline getirilmesi. Evet. Bu
da olacak. Altını ne yapıyor? Büyük
parçacık toz haline getiriyor. Nano
altın parçacıklara dönüştürüyor. Değil
mi? Bu da var. Hidrojen atomlarından
hidrojen gazı eldesi. Hayır bu aşağıdan
yukarı. Atomdan moleküle doğru çıktık.
Gördün mü? Bu aşağıdan yukarıdır. Gitti.
Cevap ne olacaktır? C seçeneği. 1 ve 3.
Diyor ki, "Yeşil sentezde hammadde
olarak hangileri kullanılabilir?
Biyolojik demiştik, değil mi? Biyolojik
sentez, yeşil sentez. Bu şekilde
söylemiştik. Evsel atıkları
kullanıyordu, bitki kökleri
kullanılıyordu, mayalar kullanılıyordu.
Bunları söylemiştik. O yüzden cevap ne
olacak? E seçeneği. Şimdi geçmişten
günümüze bir sürü metal keşfedilmiş ki
şu anda işte yaklaşık olarak 91 tane
metalden bahsediyoruz. Geçmişten
günümüze keşfedilen metaller. E bu
metallerin bazısı ağır metal olarak
ifade ediliyor. Ağır metal dediğimiz şey
nedir? Yüksek yoğunluğa sahiptir ki atom
ağırlıkları yüksek. Yoğunlukları 5 gr/
cm³ten daha fazla olan elementlere biz
ağır metal diyoruz. İşte bu ağır
metallerin bazıları ki çoğunluğu
diyebilirim. Vücutta veya işte çevrede
veya işte bitkide ne yapıyor? Zararlı
etkiler yapıyor. Bu haliyle nano
parçacıkları elde ederken bazen bunları
doğaya istemeden bırakmış oluyoruz. Peki
bunlar ne tür zararlar oluşturur? Bu
maddeler nedir? Şöyle istersen
bahsedelim. Mesela kurşun önemli bir
ağır metaldir. Kadmiyum aynı şekilde
krom, demir, kobalt, bakır, nikel, civa
ve çinko gibi örnekler vermişiz burada.
E tabii ki burada en zararlıları
içerisinde civayı söyleyebilirim.
kurşunu kadmiyumu söyleyebilirim. İki
mesela nikel kadmiyum piller vardır. Bak
o şey şarjlı pillerdir. Eskiden
kullanılıyordu. Bunlar mesela doğaya
böyle öylesine bırakıldığında ne
olacaktır? Ağır metal kirliliğine sebep
olacaktır. Haliyle teknoloji geliştikçe
metallerin de geliştiğini biliyoruz.
Eskiden işte ne yapılıyordu savaşlarda?
Bronzdan belki kılıçlar kullanılıyordu.
Sonra işte demirden kılıçlar kullanmaya
başladı. Sonra bunun paslandığını, şunu
bunu gördüler. Birazcık daha
geliştirelim dediler. Daha sert olsun.
kırılmasın dediler. Ne yaptılar? Çeliği
elde ettiler. Sonra geliştirdiler. A bu
paslanmaz olsun dediler. İçerisine krom
eklediler. Bir şeyler eklediler. Yani
arabalarda mesela aynı şekilde arabanın
dış kısmı paslanmasın diye farklı şeyler
eklediler falan. Yani metal teknolojisi
geçmişten gönlümüze ciddi bir şekilde
değişti ki burada da bunu gösteriyor.
Bak 1700 yıllarda kalsiyum ve demiri
kullanıyormuşuz. Yani en fazla
kullanılanlar bunlar. Sonra ne olmuş?
Birazcık daha artmaya başlamış.
İçerisine kalay, wolfram, kobalt, mangan
işte falan bunlar girmiş. 1800'lü
yıllarda bu buhar teknolojisinin olduğu
zamanlardan bahsediyoruz. Sonrasında
1900 yıllarda arabalarla birlikte bunun
içerisine neleri eklemişiz? Kurşun,
magnezyum işte bir sürü metal. Bak
görüyor musun? Buradaki metaller
eklenmiş. Sonra günümüzde ise artık ne
yapılıyor? Bu yarı metal teknolojisi
var. Ondan sonra işte şeyler yeşil
kimyada daha doğrusu şeyde var. Bu
alternatif enerji kaynaklarında güneş
panelleri, başka rüzgar türbinleri gibi
daha birçok şey geliştirildi. Haliyle
metallerin özellikleri çok değişti.
Uçaklarda kullanılanlar çok farklı. İşte
o zaman da ne oldu? Kullanılan metal
sayısı ciddi şekilde arttı ki mesela
işte günümüzde en çok kullanılanlardan
bir tanesi yine nedir? Alüminyumdur. Onu
da zaten birazdan örnekle söyleyeceğim.
E peki bu metaller niye kullanılıyor?
Yani endüstride bu metalin önemi ne? Bir
kere metalin en önemli şeylerinden bir
tanesi metalik bağının olmasıdır. Yani
metalik bağ güçlü bir etkileşimdir.
Kopmaya karşı direnci var. Şu anda
mesela örnek veriyorum binanın belki
3üncü katındasın veya en üst katındasın.
Şu anda durduğun yerden zemine
çakılmamanın sebebi aslında metalik
bağdır. Ne alaka hocam diyeceksin ya.
Senin şu anda duvarlar, zemin her yer
metal. Böyle bir hasırla örülüdür. İşte
bu metal hasırı ne yapıyorlar? Betonla
da karıştırıyorlar. birleştirip öyle şu
anda mesela üzerinde duruyorsun. Aslında
orada bir arada tutan şey metalik bağ.
Metal atomları bir arada durduğu için o
bina o şekilde ayakta durabiliyor.
Metalik bağ olmasa şu an tuzla buz
olurdu mesela binalar. Bazen eski
binalar tuzla buz yok. Neyse o
paslanmadan kaynaklıyor. Neyse boş ver
onu geçtim. Şimdi bak ısı ve elektriği
iletmeleri bu da etkilidir. Erime
noktalarının yüksek olması,
şekillendirilebilmesi ki en önemli
ifadesidir bu. İşte bu
şekillendirilebilmesinden kaynaklı
olarak da haliyle metallerin kullanımı
çok fazladır. Bak burada bazı yerlerde
hani bu metaller nerelerde çok
kullanılıyor dersek mesela bakıyoruz
kağıt endüstrisinde krom, bakır, civa,
kurşun ve nikeli çok kullanıyormuşuz.
Petrokimyada ne varmış? Kadmiyum, krom,
başka civa, kurşun, e başka kalay ve
çinkoyu kullanıyormuşuz. Ne bu? Klor
alkali üretiminde bakır ve nikel
haricindeki diğer ağır metalleri
kullanıyormuşuz. gübre sanayinde ki çok
ilginç geldi bu bana. Mesela kalay hariç
neredeyse hepsini kullanıyormuşuz.
İlginçmiş. Demir çelik sanayinde hepsi
kullanılmakta. Çünkü hepsinin metale
kattığı farklıdır. Alaşıma kattığı
farklı bir özellik var. Bundan dolayı
kullanılmakta. Enerji üretiminde ise
yine aynı şekilde hepsi kullanılmakta.
İşte bu metallerin özelliklerini
değiştirmek için alaşımlar yapılıyor
dedik ya. Alaşım neydi? Alaşım birden
fazla metalin bir araya gelerek
oluşturduğu genel olarak ifade ettiğimiz
homojen karışımlardır. Farklı şeyler
var. Ben bu kadarını bilmenizin yeterli
olduğunu düşünüyorum. Metallerin
karışımı yani birden fazla metalin eee
iki veya daha fazla metalin eriyerek
karışması sonucunda meydana gelen
karışıma biz ne diyoruz? İşte homojen
karışıma alaşım ismini veriyoruz. Bu
alaşımların çok farklı özellikleri
vardır. Bazıları inanılmaz yüksek
sıcaklığa dayanıklıdır. Mesela şöyle
örnek vereyim sana. Demir eriten potalar
vardır iç yani koskoca. O da metalden.
Onu koyuyorlar fırına. İçerisinde demir
eriyor ama o kap erimiyor. İşte ne
yapmışlar? Erime noktasını çok
yükseltecek şekilde onu geliştirmişler.
Alaşım haline getirmişler. Veya
paslanmıyor. Paslanmaz çelikten
bahsediyoruz. Veya çok hafif, çok
dayanıklı metal alaşımlar var mesela.
İşte bunların hepsi metallerin farklı
oranlarda karıştırılmasıyla yapılıyor.
Metallürji teknolojisi diyoruz buna da.
Mesela bak burada bazı örnekler vermiş.
İşte demirin sertliğinin yeterli
olmadığı durumlarda ne yapıyor? Daha
sert olan hale getirmek için ne
yapıyoruz? Çeliğe dönüştürüyoruz. Karbon
karıştırılıyor, farklı şeyler
karıştırılıyor ve çelik elde ediliyor.
Mesela madalya, başka heykel, madeni
paralarda bronz kullanılmakta. Bronz
dediğimiz şey ise bakır ve kalaydan
oluşan bir karışımdır. Mesela korozene
karşı dirençli yani paslanmaz çelik
yapmak istiyorsan demir, karbon, krom
bunları genel olarak karıştırıyoruz. E
başka farklı özellikler de katmak
istiyorsan bazen esneklik oluyor, farklı
özellikler oluyor. Bunun için mangan,
nikel gibi bazı metaller de
karıştırılıyor. Mesela elektronik
işlemlerde ne yapıyoruz? Lehimleme diye
bir olay var, değil mi? Lehim dediğimiz
olay kalay ve kurşunun karışımıdır.
Bunların işte bu lehimlerin de farklı
türleri vardır. Bu kalay ve kurşun
oranını değiştirerek ne yapıyorlar?
Lehimi ayarlıyorlar. Mesela evlerde şu
anda belki kapıya şöyle bir baksan
görürsün. Kapı kulbu böyle sarı renkli
bir şeydir, değil mi? Genel olarak öyle
söyleyeyim. Bu da mesela şeydir. Pirinç
alaşımıdır. Bunu daha önceden ben dedim.
Pirinç ne alaka ya diyordum. Tarladan
çıkıyor. Kapı kolu nasıl yapılıyor
diyordum. O pirinçten bahsetmiyoruz
tabii ki. Pirinç dediğimiz şey genel
olarak bakır ve çinko metalinin
karışmasıyla elde edilen bir nedir işte
alaşımdır. Pirinç alaşımı çok
kullanılmaktadır. Dekoratif malzeme
üretiminde, kapı kollarında, mobilya
ayaklarında birçok yerde kullanılmakta.
A bak burada da örneklerini göstermiş.
Lehim işte bu söylediğimiz olay. Kapı
kolları. Bu işte sarı renkli pirinçten
bahsediyoruz. Paslanmaz çelikten
bahsediyoruz. Bronz heykelleri de bu
şekilde gösterebiliriz. Heh. Bak burada
alüminyum dedim ya çok kullanılıyor
diye. Dur alümin diye bir alaşım var.
Hocam ne ala o? Nasıl bir isim
diyeceksin? Dur alümin falan diye böyle.
Burada olay şu. Şeye eee alüminyuma
farklı metaller karıştırıyorlar. Bakır,
magnezyum, mangan. Bunları karıştırarak
farklı oranlarda karıştırarak duralimin
diye bir alaşım gerçekleştiriyorlar. Bu
alaşım o kadar sağlam ki hatta güçlü ki
çok hafiftir. Gerçekten hafiftir. Ama
şöyle tutup bir arabayı bile
kaldırabilir. Bir şöyle nasıl
söyleyeyim? İşte şu kalınlıktaki bir
tane halatı, duralimin halatını aracı
kaldırabilecek şekilde yapabiliyorlar.
Bayağı şeydir, sağlamdır ve hafiftir.
İşte uçaklar mesela bu şekilde
yapılmakta veya işte uzay mekikleri
falan filan. Bunun belli bir kısmı
duralin alaşımıyla yapılmakta. Yani uzay
ve havacılık sektöründe çok önemli bir
alaşımdır. Ha şuna bakalım. diyor ki,
"Aşağıdakilerden hangisi alaşım
değildir?" Tunç bir alaşımdır. Bronz bu
şekilde de düşünebilirsin. Lehim
alaşımdı. Pirinç alaşımdı. Renkli altın.
A hocam yok bu sadece altın. Hayır bak
renkli altın dediği anda aklımıza neler
gelecek? Mesela kırmızı altın vardır.
Kırmızı altın. Yeşil altın vardır. Yeşil
altın. Beyaz altın vardır. Bunları
duymuşsundur. Beyaz altın farklı
renklerde. Bu nasıl yapılıyor? Mesela
kırmızı altından örnek vereyim. Kırmızı
altın bakır ve altını karıştırarak elde
ediliyor. Başka ne vardı mesela? Gümüşle
altını karıştırdığında farklı bir alaşım
elde ediyorsun. Farklı bir şey altın
elde ediyorsun. Başka ne vardı? Bir de
nikel miydi? Nikelle karıştırdığında
nikelle altını karıştırdığında da işte
farklı bir ne elde ediyorsun? İşte renk
şey elde ediyorsun. Altın elde
ediyorsun. Ama bak burada yani bu da bir
alaşım onu da söyleyelim. Elmas sadece
karbondan oluşan bir yapıdır ki bu bir
alaşım değildir. Cevabımız A seçeneği.
Burada ne diyor? Yukarıdaki ifadelerden
hangileri hem çelik hem de çelik
üretiminde kullanılan demir metali için
doğrudur? Sonuçta çelik de bir alaşım
metaller var içerisinde. Elektriği
iletir, demir de iletir. İkisi için de
ortaktır. Saftır. Demir. Saftır ama
çelik bir karışımdır. Karışımlar saf
madde değildir. Gitti. E metalik bağ
içerir. İçerisinde metaller bulunuyor.
Metallerin içerisinde ne vardır? Metalik
bağ vardır. Yani bu da ortaktır. İkisi
için de doğru olan 1 ve 3 olacaktır.
Yani E seçeneği. Mesela bu nano
parçacıkları illaki biz laboratuvarda mı
yapmak zorundayız? Acaba günlük hayatta
bulunamaz mı? bulunabilir. Burada da
örneklendiriyor. Suda bulunan koloidler,
ince taneli çöl kumu yani çok çok ince
taneli kısımları vardır. Onun içerisinde
petrol dumanı, volkanik aktivitelerden
veya orman yangınlarından çıkan duman ve
bazı atmosferik tozlar doğada üretilen
doğal nano parçacıklara örnek olarak
verilmektedir. Mesela yan ürün olarak da
çıkanları vardır. Mesela araba egzozu,
endüstriyel emisyonlar ve kaynak yapında
kullanılan lehim dumanları gibi insan
faaliyetlerindeki yan ürünlerde yine
nano parçacıklar çıkarmaktadır. O
dumanın içerisinde nano boyutta
parçacıklar bulunmaktadır. E haliyle
bunlar istem dışı olarak ne yapılıyor?
Atmosfere salınmış oluyor. İşte bu
diyebilirsin ya hocam bu atmosfere
salınmasında ne tür bir zarar olabilir?
Ya bak o dumanı çekiyorsun. Çektiğin
anda onun içerisindeki nano parçacıkları
alıyorsun. Yani zararlı maddeler de
vücuduna girebiliyor. Bu da önemli bir
ayrıntıdır. İşte bunları önlemeye
çalışıyor dedik ya yeşil kimya. İşte bu
tip dumanları, şunları bunları
engellemeye çalışıyor veya bunları
tutmaya çalışıyor. İşte bak bu eee
çeşitli olaylar sonucunda elde edilen
nano parçacıkları alıyorlar. Bu ister
doğal üretenler olsun ister yapay
olanlar olsun. E ne yapıyorlar? Bunları
işte nerelerde kullanıyoruz biz?
Otomotiv, işte elektronik, yapı sektörü,
tekstil, enerji, kağıt, kişisel bakım,
sağlık alanlarında kullanıyoruz. E
haliyle nerelerde kullanıyormuşuz?
Bakalım. İşte kullanım şekillerini
gösteriyor. Artış oranlarını gösteriyor.
2020'de mesela işte ne olmuş? %8'lik
elektronikte, otomotivden bahsediyorum.
İşte elektronikteki artışa bak. Yapı ve
inşaatta ciddi bir artış var ki
özellikle bu nanoteknolojik boyalar yani
kir tutmayan boyalarda mesela
kullanılmakta. tekstilde çok ciddi bir
artış göstermiş bu nanoteknolojinin
kullanımı. Enerji sektöründe aynı
şekilde kişisel bakım ve sağlıkta daha
henüz tam istediğimiz seviyede değil ama
ileride işte o nanobotlar, kanserle
savaşan yapılar bunlar da olabilecek.
İşte bu nano parçacıklar başka ağır
metaller. Yani bu söylediklerimiz
hangilerinden bahsediyoruz? Ağır
metaller, alaşımlar ve nanoparçacıklar
suya karışamıyor mu? Suya karışabiliyor.
İşte sucul sistem dediğimiz bu işte.
suya karıştığında zarar veriyor. Sudaki
canlıya zarar veriyor. Balık bunu yiyor.
Ondan sonra biz onu yiyoruz. Bizim
vücudumuza geçiyor. İşte bazen vardır ya
işte balıklarda ağır metal tespit edildi
falan. İşte bu ondan kaynaklanıyor.
Endüstriyel faaliyetler sonucunda doğaya
ne yapıyor? Bu nano parçacıklar veya
işte ağır metaller falan karışıyor. Ağır
metal karışınca denizdeki canlı bununla
sürekli muhatap olduğu için vücuduna
giriyor. Sonra biz onu yiyoruz.
Vücudumuzda ağır metal birikebiliyor. Ki
şöyle bir şey vardır. Bir tane istridye
türü müydü, midye türü müydü, neydi
mesela? O bayağı bir vücuttaki şeyleri,
denizdeki ağır metalleri tutuyor. Bunu
aşırı miktarda tüketen insanlarda bir
süre sonra işte titremeler falan
gerçekleşebiliyor. Hatta bununla ilgili
belki de örnek bilen varsa yorumlara
yazsın. Yani öyle bir olayla ilgili.
Yani eee bu tip şeyler olabiliyor. İşte
ağır metal birikimi vücutta sağlık
açısından ciddi bir risktir. Burada
bundan söy bahsediyoruz. İşte ne
yapıyoruz? İşte bunlar doğaya
karıştığında, suya karıştığında ekolojik
dengeyi bozar. İşte kirli deniz suyu
beslenme, solunum ve deri yoluyla su
canlılarının vücuduna girip canlı
organizmaların oradan da bizim
vücudumuza gelecek tabii ki böbrek,
ciğer, kas ve doku gibi kısımlarında
birikir. Bu biriken ağır metaller ne
yapıyor işte ve zararlı atıklar kan
dolaşımıyla ne yapabilir? vücuda
geliyor. İşte kan dolaşımını
yavaşlatabiliyor, kalp ritimlerini
bozabiliyor, sinir sistemini
bozabiliyor. İşte bunların hepsi ağır
metallerden kaynaklanıyor. O yüzden
diyoruz işte ne yapmak gerekiyor?
Çevreyi kirletmememiz gerekiyor. Biz onu
kirletik aman şey düşünsün. Denizd'eki
balık düşünsün. E sen yiyorsun. E
sonuçta diyebil ya hocam ben balık
tüketmiyorum. Kurtardın mı
zannediyorsun? Hayır kurtaramazsın.
Çünkü bu karada da aynı şeyi yapmakta.
Yani karasal yaşamı da aynı şekilde
etkilemekte. Yani yediğin ottu, etti,
şuydu, buydu o şekilde de gelmekte.
Oraya geleceğim ama şöyle söyleyelim.
Mesela deniz suyunda bulunan ağır
metallerin toksik etkisi yani zararlı
etkisi olan en fazlası civa dedik. Sonra
ne varmış? Kadmiyum, gümüş, nikel, başka
işte kurşun, krom, kalay, şinko diye
gidiyor. İşte aza doğru gidiyor. Ama en
tehlikelisi burada mesela cıvadır.
Haliyle bunun önlenmesi gerekiyor. İşte
bu ağır metaller karışıyor ya doğaya.
doğaya karışığında veya suya
karıştığında deniz yani şey sucul
ekosistem dediğimiz yani su olan
ekosistemleri korumak için
sürdürülebilir kalkınmanın 14 hedefi
diye bir şey var. Ya 14 onu bilmek
zorunda değilsin ama sonuçta bir hedef
var burada işte sürdürülebilir kalkınma
için burayı korumak için bir hedef var.
Bu hedef nelerden bahsediyor? Diyor ki
işte deniz ve kıyı ekosistemlerini
sürdürülebilir bir biçimde yönetmeyi
sağlamak istiyorlar. Buradan başka
kirlenmeden korumayı ve ayrıca okyanus
asitlenmesinin etkilerini ele almayı
hedefliyorlar. Yani acaba bu okyanustaki
asidlik ortam artınca ne oluyor, ne
zarar görüyor? İşte bunları inceliyorlar
ki mesela işte bu mercan kayalıklarının
zarar gördüğünü tespit etmişler. Mercan
kayalıkları yavaş yavaş ölüyor diyorlar.
Bunları önlemek için çeşitli çalışmalar
yapılıyor. Ha dedim ya işte ağır
metaller sadece su değil. Yani bu
alaşımlar, nanoparçacıklar kara
ekosisteminde de ne yapmakta? Zararlı
etkiler yapmakta. suya karıştı. Oradan
toprağa da karışabiliyor. E toprağa
karıştığında ne olacak? Topraktaki
canlılar bunu alacak bünyesine.
Topraktaki canlıların fizyolojik yapısı
etkilenecek bu durumdan. E haliyle
tarımda sürdürülebilirlik etkilenmiş
olacak bu durumdan. Canlılar ölmeye
başlayacak. Hadi ölmedi. İçerisinde ağır
metal oranı yüksek olduğu için. Hatta
oluyor ya bazen işte yurt dışına
gönderiyorsun. Diyorlar ki bunda şöyle
bir şey tespit ettik. Geri gönderiyorlar
falan. İşte hani bu tip durumlarla
karşılaşabiliyorsun. Ne yapmak
gerekiyor? önlemleri iyi almak
gerekiyor. İşte bu olumsuzlukları,
kirlilikleri önlememiz gerekiyor. Yani
doğaya bu salınan parçacıkların
önlenmesi gerekiyor. Kaynağında
gidereceksin burumu. Durumu. İşte
atmosfere çıkacak ya hemen oraya filtre
koyacaksın. Filtre onu engelleyecek.
Çıkmasını engelleyecek. Zaten doğaya
salmazsan kirlenmemiş olacak. Asıl
önemli olan şey bu. tutmak gerekiyor. Ha
burada da bundan bahsediyor. İşte tüm bu
olumsuzluklar ve kirlilikler ekolojik
dengenin bir unsuru olan insan sağlığını
da doğrudan veya dolaylı olarak tehdit
etmektedir. Yani sen bunu aldın
vücuduna, vücudun zarar gördü. Demin
verdiğim örnek işte aşırı miktarda belli
bir şey yiyorsun. Onun içerisinde ağır
metal fazla olduğu için vücutta sinir
sistemi zarar görebiliyor. İşte bu
karasal ekosistemi korumak için de
sürdürülebilir kalkınmanın 15. maddesi
var. 15. hedefi var. kara ekosistemini
korumak, iyileştirmek ve sürdürülebilir
kullanımını arttırmaya çalışıyormuşuz,
destekliyormuşuz. Kuraklık ve çölleşme
ile mücadele, sürdürülebilir orman
denetimi ve yönetimi sağlama. Mesela
şöyle şeyler vardır. Kağıt üretmek
gerekiyor, değil mi? Tamam. Kağıdı işte
atık kağıtlardan üretebiliyoruz ama her
zaman yetmiyor bu. E haliyle atık
kağıttan ürettin. Normal ağaçtan da elde
etmen gerekiyor. Bunun için de şeyler
var. Ağaç için endüstriyel ağaç
yetiştirmi var. İşte ne yapıyorlar?
endüstriyel olarak o ağacı yetiştiriyor.
Oradan kağıt elde ediyor. Bir bir daha
oraya dikiyor. Sürekli o şeyi kısmı ne
yapıyor? Yenilemiş oluyor. Ama doğaya
yani daha doğrusu ormanlara zarar
vermemiş oluyor. Yani kağıt için ayrı
böyle endüstriyel ağaçlar
yetiştiriyorlar. arazilerin rastgele
bozulmasına engel olmak ve arazi geri
kazanılması işte bu şeylerle de
olabiliyor. Heyelanlarla, şunlarla,
bunlarla tarım arazileri bazen
kaybolabiliyor. Bunları önlemek için
çalışmalar yapılıyor. Mesela e biyolojik
çeşitliliği korumak zaten en önemli
şeylerden bir tanesidir. Doğadakilerden
bir tanesi bile gittiğinde onunla
bağlantılı birçok canlı etkilenmekte. O
yüzden ne olması gerekiyor? işte
biyolojik çeşitliliğin korunması
gerekiyor. İşte bu yeşil kimyanın
sürdürülebilirlik, doğal kaynakların ve
ekolojik dengenin korunması adına
yaptığı bazı şeyler vardır ki nedir
bunlar? Mesela fosil yakıt tüketimini
azaltmaya çalışıyor. Alternatif enerji
kaynaklarına geçiyor. Enerji tasarrufu
sağlıyor ki hani kullandım bari daha az
kullanayım. Bu amacı güdüyor. Mesela
fosil kökenli plastik ürün kullanımını
azaltmaya çalışıyor. Geri
dönüştürülebilirler veya doğada
çözünebilir olanları kullanıyor. Geri
dönüşüme önem veriyor ki çok önem
veriyor. Yeşil kimyanın ilkelerini
bilmek ve uygulamak, zararlı kimyasalın
kullanımını azaltmak. İşte bunlar en
önemli tedbirlerden bazılarıdır. Yani
yeşil kimyada bu tedbirler alınması
gereken tedbirler. Benim mavi gözlüm
değerli insan Atatürk ne demiş biliyor
musun? Bak çok güzel bir ifadesi var.
diyor ki, "Milli ekonominin temeli
ziraattir." demiş. Yani tarım bizim için
çok değerlidir. Atatürk'ü biliyorsunuz.
Yani inanılmaz ileri görüşlü bir insan.
Muhteşem bir insan ve eee söylediği
birçok şeyde zamanla gerçekleşen bir
insan. İşte bu ifadeyi kullanıyorsa yani
milli ekonominin temeli ziraattir
diyorsa ki bunu da bak görmeye başladık.
Ne diyorlar? İleride gıda savaşları,
gıda sıkıntısı, kıtlıklar bunlar
olabilir gibi böyle ifadeler
kullanılıyor. Bak Atatürk ta ne zaman
demiş ki ne zaman işte 1925 yılında da
buna önlem almış. Ne yapmış? Atatürk
orman çiftliğini kurduruyor. Burada
mesela işte şeyler, sığırlar
geliştiriliyor, yetiştiriliyor. Bitkiler
yetiştiriliyor. Burada işte meyve ve
sebzeler yetiştiriliyor. Arazi
şartlarına uygun meyve sebze
yetiştirmesi. Bununla ilgili ciddi
çalışmalar yapıyor Atatürk. işte ileri
görüşlülüğünü burada da gösteriyor. İşte
bu tarımsal kalkınma yöntemleri
Atatürk'ün ta koyduğu yöntemler
geliştirilerek devam ederse eğer ileride
gıda sıkıntısı yaşamayız. Bizim için
önemlidir. Tarım arazilerini korumamız
gerekiyor. O araziye uygun ürünlerin
yetiştirilmesi gerekiyor. Hayvancılığın
geliştirilmesi gerekiyor ki işte bak
Atatürk bununla ilgili ciddi şekilde
çalışmalar yapmış. Ha bu arada tabii
günümüzde yok mu? Var. Benim bizzat
öğrencilerimin yaptığı çalışmalar var ki
bu tahıl cinslerinin ıslahı, eee,
bunların halka dağıtımı ki bunu yapıyor
mesela onla ilgili çalışmaları var. Bu
ata tohumlarını geliştiriyorlar mesela.
Ata tohumlarını geliştirerek işte bize
ait ırkları, bize ait sağlıklı şeyleri,
tahılları yetiştirmeye çalışıyorlar.
Bununla ilgili ciddi çalışmaları var. Bu
hibrit tohumlar vardır. Eee, malum
terörist ülkenin eee, tohumları. onları
kullanmak yerine işte kendi
tohumlarımızı kullanmak adına çalışmalar
yapılıyor. Şu anda var. Eee hatta bizzat
öğrencim de yapıyor bu çalışmaları. O
yüzden hani eee aa geçmişte yapıldı
bitti mi? Hayır. Ama daha da
geliştirilmesi lazım. Bu önemli. Hadi
soru çözelim de bitirelim. Bak ne diyor.
Çinko, krom, başka, kurşun, nikel. E
bunlar ağır metaldi değil mi? Heh. Ağır
metal olarak adlandırılır. Evet. Ağır
metaller neydi? Yoğunluğu 5 gr/ cm³ten
yüksekti. E toksik etkiye ağır metaller
vücutta zararlı etkiye sahiptir.
Doğrudur. Hepsi doğru oldu. Cevap E
seçeneği. Diyor ki doğal ve insan
faaliyetleri sonucunda meydana gelen
sucul kirlilik, suyu kirleten
durumlardan bahsediyoruz. Sadece su
canlılarını etkiler. Hayır demiştim ya.
Sudaki canlıyı başka karada yaşayan bir
canlı yediğinde onun vücudunda birikerek
onu da etkileyebilir. Sadece sudakini
etkilemez. Genel olarak ağır metalli
atıkları ve nanoparçacıklardan
kaynaklanır. Evet, doğrudur. Sanayi
atıklarının rastgele arıtılmadan sulara
bırakılması su ekosisteminin
kirlenmesine neden olur. Evet, doğru bir
ifadedir. Kesinlikle ve kesinlikle en
önemli şeylerden bir tanesi sanayi
atıklarını arıtarak doğaya vermektir. Ya
rica ediyorum, yalvarıyorum. Varsa
tanıdığı olan onlar da söylesin. Ne olur
ya bak ettiğiniz zararı düşünmeyin ya.
İşte ben bu işte filtre sistemine şu
kadar para vereceğim de işte çok zararım
olur. Ya bir kere zarar edeceksin. Ondan
sonra aldığın duayı düşün ya. Ya bak
duayı kirletmek yerine ne yapacaksın
aslında? Ciddi gelecek nesillerden dua
almış olacaksın. Azıcık bir kul hakkını
da düşünün ya. Şu şeyi, çevreyi
kirletmeyin lütfen. Hah o zaman neyse
çok sinirlendim. Cevap 2 ve 3 oldu değil
mi? Heh. D seçeneği. Aha da konu bitti.
Tüm 9. sınıfı bitirmiş olduk. Buraya
kadar benimle beraber geldiğin için sana
sonsuz teşekkür ediyorum. Konuları
bitirdik. Bu son konu. Dikkatini
çektiyse böyle sözel bir konu. Kendin de
okuyabilirsin, benden de
dinleyebilirsin. Fark etmez. Ben bazen
böyle ufak tefek eklemeler yapıyorum ama
kendinde okuyabileceğim bir konudur bu.
Tabii ki sınavda da bununla ilgili genel
geçer ifadeler kullanılacaktır. Yani çok
rahat bir şekilde okuduğunda anladığı,
anlayabileceğin kolay sorular gelecektir
buradan. Çok böyle yoğun geleceğini
düşünmüyorum. Buradan üniversite
sınavında buradan soru gelir mi?
Tartışılır açıkçası. belki ağır metal
kısımlarından falan gelebilir ama şu an
tabii söylediğim 4 yıl 34 yıl
sonrasından bahsediyorum. Sizin
gireceğiniz sınavdan bahsediyorum ama
genel olarak yani burası sözel basit bir
kısımdır. Bilinçlenmek için koyulmuş bir
kısımdır burası. Önemli olan kısım bu.
İnşallah yani en büyük şeyim e hayalim
eee bu okullardaki laboratuvarlarda
nanoteknoloji ile ilgili çalışmalar
yapılır diye ümit ediyorum. İnşallah
bununla ilgili çalışmalar yapılır.
Devletimiz bu konuya el atarsa aşırı
mutlu olurum açıkçası. Okullarda
nanoteknoloji ile ilgili çalışmalar
yapılırsa, bununla ilgili laboratuvar
işlemleri yapılırsa ya öğrencilere en
azından bununla ilgili bir
bilinçlendirmek için laboratuvar
çalışmaları yapılırsa inanılmaz mutlu
olurum. İnşallah bunu da görürüm. Şimdi
dostum bak buraya kadar geldin. Daha
devam edeceğiz. Soru çözümlerimiz
olacak. Çeşitli çalışmalar yapacağım
yine. Eee ve şöyle bir şey var. Seneye
10. sınıf oluyorsun. Artık bu senenin
müfredatını bitirdin. 10. sınıf
olacaksın. 10. sınıf müfredatında mol
falan var. Benimle beraber kal. Bende
kal. Bak sana rica ediyorum. Bende kal.
Sana molü öğreteyim. Çok önemli bir
kısımdır. Orayı hallettiğinde sonrası
gerçekten akıp gidecek. Mol çok
önemlidir. Seneyeden bahsediyorum tabii
ki. O yüzden şimdiden önlemini alman
gereken bir durum var. O da şu.
Matematikte temel atman lazım. Nelerden
bahsediyorum? Ondalık sayılar, kesirli
sayılar, üslü ifadeler, oran orantı,
sadeleştirme. Bunları iyi öğren dostum.
Bak bunları iyi öğrenirsen kimyada
seneye rahat edersin. Net bir şekilde
söylüyorum. Hocam mol yapamıyorum.
Seneye bu ifadeleri duyacağım
bazılarınızdan. İşte bunun çözümü bu
saydığım kısımlar. Matematikte bu
saydığım kısımları halledersen olay
bitiyor dostum. Şu kanala abone olma
işini söylemeyeyim değil mi? Abone
olursun diye düşünüyorum. Bak buraya
kadar geldin. Seneye de devam edeceğiz.
Ondan sonraki sene var. Sınava
gireceğiz. Ondan sonra da e haliyle sana
destek vermeye devam edeceğim. Senden de
destek bekliyorum. Biliyorsun
laboratuvar kurma hayalim var. Bu
hayalimde yanımda olursan çok mutlu
olurum. İki fosforbi asit kimya. Bu
kadar basit. Görüşmek üzere.